hello everyone and welcome to a truly
amazing game from round six of the melt
weather champions chester finals uh a
lot of you have already started
requesting it even though it just
happened after four rounds of rapid that
ended ended in the draw uh here we have
the first game of the blitz section as
the little robot there suggests uh and
it's just a spectacular uh adventurous
game uh let's check it out and and see
what what happens here so anish with the
white pieces opens with e4 we had a lot
of english openings in the rapid time
section but now it's time for the
sicilian so c5 uh magnus goes for the
sicilian defense knight f3 knights the
c6 and bishop to b5 now going for danish
we
medina
e6 and now castles by anish we have
knight to g to e7 uh and now striking in
the center with d4 we have captures
on d4 captures on d4 and queen to b6
going after the knight here but also
attacking the bishop we have bishop to
e3 now defending the knight
and here we have knight captures on d4
it seems like you're losing the bishop
here but not really and he's just
defends it with a4 and you're gonna win
back your piece uh on the next move uh
is something that would usually happen
for example if magnus defends with e5
we're gonna play c3 and we're still
gonna win back our piece but magnus says
uh nope you're not winning back your
piece i'm gonna give up the queen and
here
magnus plays knight captures on b5 so he
grabs a second piece and offers a queen
but it comes with a with a little trick
because after bishop captures on b6 we
have eight captures on b6 and anish
cannot capture back the knight because
the rook on a1 would hang so it's
basically three pieces for the queen
so how can anish continue this knight to
d2 now the knight can be captured the
queen is guarding the rook here and
magnus just goes back knight to d6 so uh
here if you check out the position
magnus has the bishop's pair and a
knight for a queen now this is uh
materialistically compensation enough in
itself but he still has to develop those
pieces none of those pieces are uh
in the game so he starts with e5 uh
anish starts with e5 challenges the
knight and now knight d to f5 this is an
excellent square for the knight uh so at
some point we will dislodge it with g4
we have knights to e4 and goes for
knights to d6 check and now knights to
c6 of course preventing this uh we have
g4 chasing this knight away and the
knights the h for now uh we have f4 now
the the rook also guards the f3 square
so you don't have to worry about this
knight here but also you really just
want to open up the position and start
going after carlson's king before he
develops his pieces so h5 he says all
right you want to open up the position
let's open up the position my rook would
very much enjoy a nice open or a
semi-open h file with h3 uh you could
also block this with the g5 but then you
again allow this knight this beautiful
f5 square and that's something anish
doesn't want to do so h captures h
captures on g4 and now magnus strikes in
the center with the d5 he has to give up
some material uh in order to develop his
pieces anish uh captures this very
happily e captures and e6 alpha song and
now rook to a5 going after rook to d5
attacking the queen and now he will be
able to win back his pawn so c4 anish
prevents this and now f5 further opening
up the position uh he wants to attack
that white king he does have the bishop
pair uh but it's still a question of how
you will develop this bishop pair and
now anish goes for b4 uh he saw a couple
of my videos and he always um uh and he
saw that always be four wins for white
but here
it doesn't win right away on the spot
but it's still a great move so he
dislodges this knight otherwise you're
gonna have to move away the rook so
knight captures on b4 and now he
sacrifices this pawn with d7 check we
have bishop captures on d7 and now
knight the d6 with check and now the
knight has to be captured if you don't
capture it if you go for example here
the knight to f7 check
picks up the rook and king the e7 will
further
uh well just
make problems uh you you will not be
able to develop your pieces so bishop
captures on d6 we have queen captures on
d6 and now knight back to c6 and now
finally rook 8 to d1 threatening queen
captures on d7 so how can magnus defend
here there's only one move bishop to c8
it looks like such an ugly move but if
you look at the position there's really
nothing anish can do here to to try and
go for something here so in fact rook 8
d1 was not maybe the greatest move but
it's hard to you know play play a good
move here you are down uh three three
pieces for the queen and this is a blitz
game
so what can you play here anish
continues with the ge5 we have knight
back the g6 uh we have rook to f2 now
preparing to double up uh and the king
to f7 now we have queen to c7 with the
check maybe going after the b6 spawn but
the just knight seat the e7 you don't
care about the b6 pawn you're going to
capture on a4 then you're going to go
after the c4 pawn so rook to d8 anisha
offers a trade of rooks and magnus
trades here we have rook captures queen
captures and now rook captures an a4 uh
queen to c7 guarding the c4 pawn but now
comes e5 magnus wants to open up the
position as uh he needs uh
he he needs to attack
with f captures on e5 this is good for
anish as well as this rook might now
come alive and adjust the bishop to e6
attacking the c4 pawn twice we have
queen captures on b7 rook captures on c4
and now queen captures on b6 and we've
eliminated all of the pawns on the queen
side now it's a matter of um
well this structure here in in front of
carlson's king
can anish do something about it or is it
just rock solid so knight captures an e5
grabbing yet another pawn and now rook
to e2 attacking the knight here now just
a rook to c6 attacking the queen queen
back to e3 putting pressure on the
knight and now knight five back to g6
and now
this position does seem to be
impenetrable and it's uh not easy to
play this with white whatever you do you
simply cannot make a single thread or as
our good friend capoblanca would say the
the position is unassailable
if you remember it from the capoblanca
saga but okay king h2 anish has to play
something bishop the c for now uh
putting pressure on the rook then the
rook can come to e6 we can bring the
other
rook to e2 so a lot of a lot of options
here we have rook to b2 now comes rook
to e6 attacks the queen queen to f3 and
now rook to e4
so now we're ready to start harassing
that white king but also we might be
interested in maybe pushing the pawn to
f4 uh then uh chasing back the queen
then maybe putting the bishop on this
diagonal then advancing the pawn even
further this could be
just just a very enjoyable pass pawn so
rook to b7
now you have to be careful the f pawn is
hanging the knight is pinned here so
bishop back to e6 defending the spawn
now king the g1 uh we have rooked the g4
check king to h2 and now rook captures
on g5 eliminating uh white's last pawn
and now magnus will try and figure out a
way on how to advance here so rook to b6
and now comes bishop to d5 attacking the
queen here the queen now has to move
queen to e3 and now rook the g2 with
check of course you cannot go to h1 then
we simply win the queen so king has to
go to h3 now comes rook to g4 uh the the
defending the f4 square now you can play
f4 f3 and further advance your your pawn
uh king to h2 now comes f4 attacks the
white queen queen to d4 and now rook to
g5 just defending the bishop here not
allowing whites to
try any tricks here rook to d6 uh and
now we have f3
everything is nicely defended so there's
nothing to worry about here rook to d7
and now we have rook to f5 putting the
rook behind the pass pawn as one should
always do uh queen to g4
and now bishop to e6 of course you were
not thinking about advancing the pawn
further if you do this then this just
wins for white the knight is spinned uh
so of course magnus prevents this bishop
to e6 now comes rook to d1 you have to
try and stop the pass pawn now but it's
not going to be easy knight to e5
attacks the queen queen to h4 now comes
f2 king to g2 guards the f1 square with
the king and the rook but now we have
bishop to d5 with check king f1 and now
bishop c4 check regarding the
f1 square twice now king to g2 and now
f1 queen and he was in this position on
mu 53 that anish giri resigned the game
and the game one of the blitz section
goes to magnus which means he's not has
taken the lead in the match and we'll
see what happens in game two can anish
equalize and take it to armageddon or uh
will it will it just be a a win for
magnus
uh so yeah here you resign because
you're in check and you are down simply
too much material and if you capture the
queen then we can simply play check and
it's over very quickly for example rook
g3 rook f3 check king h2 we can even
give up some material to win back the
queen and now for example after
everything gets traded down uh we're
winning we have the the past pawn so uh
of course completely winning for black
yeah after f1 queen uh magnus brings his
queen back into the game and and wins uh
a brilliant brilliant game and it's
interesting that
this is something that anish prepared
but it's magnus who who surprised him
with this completely new knight captures
on b5 queen uh sacrifice or rather
giving up a queen for three pieces uh
but so early in the game on move eight
this is just very very impressive stuff
and although it's not objectively good
for a blitz game where anish probably
saw this for the first time
it seems to be more than more than good
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank andre
frantischek uh balcovich enterprises uh
ben mcgregorian aaron anderson and mr
hoody guy for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
incredible event until it ends
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day